hey everybody sorry about that
and in realised stream was was already
up it's Jesse and if you haven't watched
before this this show is just about me
doing my work I'm a front-end developer
and I want to show my normal work and
you'll see all my mistakes and
everything and just get an idea for what
it's like for a front-end developer to
work at least for me today we have a
very ambitious plan we're going to set
up from scratch a digitalocean droplet a
server to be able to run react I'm not
I'm almost positive there's no way I can
get this done in a half an hour so hey
guys everybody's saying hi in the live
chat so I have two options either I
split this up and do it over two days so
today and tomorrow or I can just try to
do an extra long video today and try to
get it all done so I think it'll
probably depend on how many people are
watching at the end of a half an hour if
there's a lot of viewers maybe I'll just
keep going if it's kind of dropping off
then we'll see maybe I'll split it up
into two videos but either way I need to
have it done because I'd like to have
something up and running to show the
people that I'm making this site for uh
show them what's going on and to test it
working with the API where all the
content is going to come from okay so oh
we have opposing viewpoints in the live
chat someone saying split it up into two
videos someone's saying make it work
today all right we'll see I'll think
about it we'll see how far we get if
we're close
we're close to being done then maybe
maybe we'll go a little bit longer but
if I think it's going to take like an
extra hour then they've helped us split
it up so I haven't set up a server in
this way and probably maybe like three
months so we'll see I'm I'll be a little
rusty
so before we start real quick uh the
site this site that I'm working on now
is probably going to launch May 25th is
the official launch date now unless that
changes after that I'm going to start
doing tutorial videos on my channel the
link is in the description I'll do all
the livestream still in free code camp
and then I'll just throw the tutorial
videos on my own channel I had a lot of
suggestions for different things to do
tutorials on so I'm keeping a list of
everything that you all suggest in the
live chat or in the comments and I'd
like to do some short very focused
videos on each one of those topics
alright the rest of the week in case you
haven't seen this yet I've showed that
the last couple of videos tomorrow is
also a different time than normal it's
going to be 11:30 a.m. sorry about the
time change this is just because I have
so many meetings today and tomorrow
Wednesday I will be traveling to a
conference to syntax Khan so I don't
know if I'll be able to livestream or
when so I'll just put it on Twitter when
I'm going to livestream and I think
you're getting alert if you're
subscribed to free code camp if you want
to get the the tweet as well then follow
me on Twitter
the link to my Twitter account is also
in the description and in Thursday and
Friday I'll be at syntax Khan I did get
permission from the people with syntax
Khan to record and livestream as long as
the speakers are cool with it so I have
some ideas for what to do but I want to
know what you want to see okay so I'm
going to this syntax Khan they're going
to have front-end stuff back-end stuff
and some talks on different platforms
so let me know I was thinking maybe I
could do interviews with some of the
speakers or even some other people there
maybe I could just do quick recaps of
the sessions that I go to and just show
some of the highlights so I'm not really
sure what you want to see what would be
you know realistic to do I'm also not
really sure how good the Wi-Fi is going
to be so there might be pre-recorded
video so instead of live streams but let
me know in the live chat or in the
comments what you would like to see as
long as you comment before your Thursday
morning then I'll be able to read it and
hopefully do whatever you guys you know
want me to do whatever you want to say
alright so let's get started since we
have a lot to do I'm going to be
neglecting the live chat slightly more
than usual today because there's so much
to do and I don't want to miss a step
because it could can mess things up all
right cool somebody said just start bruh
alright so I want to start this from
scratch so I did the very first step
beforehand I'll just show you what that
was I logged on to digitalocean
I already have an account on
digitalocean I just went in I clicked
create droplet and I came to this screen
we're selecting ubuntu 16.04 we've
chosen the five dollar-a-month droplet
we can always scale this up later if we
get a lot of traffic but for now this
should work and then you can pick a New
York data centers or closest to my
location so that's what I pick I've
added the ipv6 networking I forgot to
click the monitoring which I should have
you can always add it in later but it's
a little bit harder so I would recommend
just clicking the monitoring I didn't
need any of this other stuff right now I
already have my SSH keys added in here
and these are some of the SSH keys for
my colleagues so if you don't have these
added in you can add them in later on
you've created the droplet and then you
just give it a name then you click
create and it's as easy as that and then
you have your droplet up and running so
this is my droplet now so I can get my
IP address and log into the droplet the
first step to log in is simply to put in
in in your terminal SSH and then route
at and then you put in your IP address
okay assuming that you had your SSH key
set up already
then it logs you in and you're good to
go
I'm not going to go over the SSH key
things since I already had them set up
but I definitely recommend using it I'll
probably do a video on it at some point
is it's it's pretty important you use it
a lot but it saves you from having that
passwords in fact we're going to
completely disable passwords on the
server and just have you have the SSH
keys and it'll just make it a little bit
more secure since there'll be no way to
log in with the password so if you want
to follow along I always use the
instructions on digitalocean to set this
up when I go through it doesn't matter
how many times I do it if you miss a
step
then it things might not work right or
it might be bad for security so I always
just follow along a lot of the steps I
remember and I could do pretty quickly
but I don't want to trust that to memory
I have the links in the description
first we're going to install a what
we're going to set up Lubuntu it's
already installed and then we're going
to move on to nginx and then we'll see
how far we can go maybe we'll get to
note after that but the first two
tutorials are linked in the description
all right so I am now on step two if you
want to follow along and we're going to
create a user because we don't want to
log in this route all the time so we
actually are pretty much never going to
use route again after we create this
other user so I'm just going to go add
user sometimes I'm going to type them
out sometimes I'm just going to copy and
paste them I don't think there's
anything wrong with copy
pasting things into the terminal because
you know one one mistake in the command
doesn't work so for longer commands
copying pasting is the way to go and I'm
just going to make the user Jesse it can
be anything it's going to ask you for a
password
this is not the login password it's
going to ask you for some of your info
you don't really need to fill this up if
you're in kind of a bigger organization
maybe you might want to fill this out so
people know who you are it's primarily
going to be me logging in and working on
this so it doesn't really matter I'll
just put my name okay so now that user
is set up and we need to give that user
root privileges okay so that password
that we just typed in that's not your
login password remember there will be no
login password it's just going to be SSH
keys to get in this password is going to
be what you use when you try to use sudo
which means basically this user called
jesse is going to have privileges to do
things that only root can normally do
I'll need to run the command sudo to be
able to do those things as if I were the
root user and I'm going to need that
password so if anybody were to ever
somehow get on my machine so they have
my SSH key and be able to log in as as
Jesse as me they would still need to
know my password to actually do anything
as the root user and generally root
command sort I mean they can mess up
your whole server you could do anything
as root so it's an added layer of
security it's slightly annoying enough
to retype your password but it's
definitely definitely better to have
that a little bit of security I don't
recommend having no password for that
I've never tried to do that but I assume
it's possible okay so now we're going to
give the privileges I'm going to copy
and paste this
so the example name they're using in the
digitalocean instructions of Sammy so I
just need to change Sammy - Jesse okay
and now that user has sudo privileges if
you're following along with me we're
going to skip step four because I've
already done this earlier so if you
haven't set up your SSH keys then you
will need to do step four if you are
using digitalocean I recommend you know
set those up so that you can use them in
the actual creation of the droplet and
it will save you some time so we're
skipping all the way to step five and
this is optional but recommended we're
going to disable password authentication
so I don't I don't want anybody to be
able to use a password to log into the
server so what I'm going to do before
that is i'm actually going to log out of
the root user think exit there we go so
I just typed exit that logged me out and
now I'm going to SSH back in but I'm
going to change from root to Jessie woo
and it denied my thinking no I guess I
skipped a step this is the point of
doing this live so you see when I mess
up and hopefully you don't feel bad as
you when you mess up because I've
already done it I'm going to scroll up
quickly and see what I missed
oh okay I'm I'm pretty sure I need to
add my public key to a file in the root
directory for that user so good thing I
didn't disable the root yet which we
will do but because I need to get back
in there so what I'm going to do is as
the root user I'm going to switch to
Jessie so I've actually went from root
and now I'm it's as if I am this user
briefly out I'll be this user now I'm
automatically in the home directory for
this user so we can see the directory
we're in so home Jessie and we're going
to make a directory for our SSH key so
we've just made this directory and now
we're going to change the the privileges
for that directory that's with the with
this command us and we'll change it back
to put that kind of lock that down after
we we first we first put that in okay so
we use an Anna so we're going to use
Nano okay so if you're not familiar with
Nano it's just an editor that you can
use in a terminal some people prefer
them that's a little bit more
complicated I'm not really good with it
maybe one day I'll take some more time
to practice but Nano is the the simplest
editor so if you're new use user Nana
it's it's pretty easy okay so what I
need to do now is to insert my public
key so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to
now I have to actually go to my public
key so just take me a second find my
public key
actually see
sorry for the delay I'm doing this on my
other monitor just so that I don't
accidentally show the world something
that they shouldn't see in terms of
passwords or anything like that so as
soon as I get this I will switch back
over and start running some commands
again
okay
all right so what I've done off screen
is I went through the command line I
went to my SSH folder for my local user
on my machine and I found the public key
file and I just copied and pasted that
public key into this folder here when
you're done with with Nano the way you
exit out as I just press control X and
it'll ask me if I want to save if I type
Y I hit enter it asked me what file name
I want I obviously wanted to keep the
same name so I hit enter so in case you
haven't used Nano it's pretty easy now
what we tried to do a minute ago should
work all right I just glanced at the
live chats I'm going to answer this
question real quick because I think it's
important
someone says is this the work of a
front-end developer technically no I I
guess like you might consider this like
DevOps stuff I mean correct me if that's
not really the right term but what will
happen is if you're a freelancer you'll
probably have to do this stuff if you
are working in a small team at a company
somewhere you'll probably have to do
this stuff if if there's no other person
dedicated to this kind of thing you will
have to do it at some point if you ever
want your site to be you know live on a
real server somewhere you'll have to do
some something like this so it's good to
know not exactly a friend developer work
but it's you know it's something that
you probably should learn how to do
because you you may need to do it all
right so now let's attempt to do what we
did before and that is let's exit and we
need to exit twice remember because we
went into the user account with the name
of Jesse from root so now we're back in
root and we want to get
all the way out to my local machine now
I'm in my local machine and I'm gonna
tell you
Jesse if you're wondering uh no oh no
this is an epic fail guys ah I know
exactly what I did I skipped a step
sorry guys not a great day today I'm
much better in the afternoons if you've
watched my other streams they're usually
after news all right so remember we were
kind of relaxed the permissions on this
file and we never restricted them I'm
guessing that may have something to do
with the reason why this isn't working
so we're going to go back into that user
and I'm going to check I'll make sure
okay we do have that directory so that
that's there okay we do the authorized
keys I'm just going to double check to
make sure that the keys there that's all
I'm going to move off the screen briefly
not that anybody could probably use my
public key if it because they won't have
a private key but just in case there's
some way I don't know about to do
something bad with that key I'm going it
off-screen okay I'm checking this file
out right now it I have the key okay so
all that seems it seems right and so now
I'm just going to reset this back to
what it should be and we're going to
type exit ok and
I'm actually going to copy this let's
see I'm going to copy this and just try
it over here so I don't have to log out
again in case it doesn't work ah it's
not working again anybody see anybody
out there me do you see what I'm missing
this is the first time this has ever
happen to me I've set up servers like
this several times in the past six
months or so and I've never had this
happen so what we can do that I don't
normally do is I can just continue on as
the root user and do some of these
things and I will try to figure out what
is wrong later on I'm just I'm
double-checking my huh
and just double check in the directions
real quick yeah alone I didn't miss
anything
not sure what's happening I suppose it's
like some simple thing that I just I'm
not saying so what we'll do is we'll
continue as the root user and go as far
as we can as the root user and we're
almost up to half an hour anyway so I'd
hope to be further along but this is a
good example of how things really work
sometimes sometimes you got to do
something you've done before and it's
always worked before and now it doesn't
work and you can't figure it out so I'm
sure anybody that's been a developer for
any length of time has experienced
something like this so is it somebody
asked if it's free to try digitalocean
no but you can usually find some dish
and credit so yeah all right so somebody
mentioned the github student pack gives
free credits just search online for a
code to have get free free time on
digitalocean you'll find it I think I
found something it was like twenty five
dollars free but usually you can at
least find ten or fifteen dollars
somewhere I think I can give out a link
that'll give you at least ten dollars
but I mean if you want me to send you
the link that's fine let me know but I
think you can find an even better one
like at least maybe fifteen to twenty
five out there if you take the time to
look okay so the last thing that we at
least can do is I can show you how to
disable passwords on your server
normally you would do this you can do
this as user but normally after I set up
the other user I never use root again
and I disable root but obviously I can't
do that right now since I can't get that
other user working so what I've done let
me uh I've typed in our copied and
pasted in Nano I've opened the sshd
underscore config file so that's what
we're in this is the our configuration
file for SSH login basically and we're
going to find the line that talks about
password authentication so let's see
what is it at that pass it up
probably
there we go okay password authentication
oh it's actually defaulted - no probably
because I hmm I don't know why I devoted
- no I've done it before and it's been
default at the s so we don't have to
change that but there are a few other
things that we want to change so since
we want to do authentication just with
the keys we need to check we'll just
check these other things out they may
already be set when I sometimes when
I've done this in the past these
actually have been set to different
values so maybe maybe the defaults have
changed so we want to check public key
authentication and make sure that that
is set to yes so I have the font so
bigots I can't see the whole file so I'm
doing a lot of scrolling around to make
sure there we go
okay public key authentication we need
is set to yes and we want to set
challenge/response authentication to no
or at least make sure that it's set to
no
okay there we go
challenge response authentication no
that's all we need so let's get out of
this by pressing ctrl X if you haven't
made any changes in Ana when you hit
ctrl X it doesn't ask you to save the
changes or anything you're just going to
take you right out okay we didn't really
change anything but if we had we would
want to do this I'll show you the
command in a second we want to reload
the system if we had so we'll go ahead
and do it just to show you and this is
the command that you'll want to use okay
and then any changes you add would take
effect after you've done that so the
next step if you're following along on
the digitalocean instructions is
actually to test the the login for your
new user we've tested it several times
it won't work so so we're just going to
skip to the next step and I'll fix this
later on and what we're going to do now
is set up a basic firewall so first we
can check to see what's going on right
now with our firewalls so we have
OpenSSH running or that's available we
want to allow this so we're going to
type in ufw allow open SSH we obviously
need this to worker we can't login all
right so we've allowed that the rules
are updated now we need to enable our
firewall so really simple ufw enable and
so now our firewall command may disrupt
existing connections yeah that's fine
okay um it always says that but I've
never actually had a connection
disrupted
now we want to check to make sure it's
running so we can just type ufw status
and it will show we do have our firewall
running but we have our open SSH and the
v6 for the ipv6 allowed it so that that
lets us log in later on not today but
maybe tomorrow's tutorial will add to
this list but for now this is all we
need and that takes us to the end of the
first guide we've set up
Lubuntu next step is to set up nginx
that's going to be our reverse proxy at
some point and we'll go over that
probably tomorrow because I don't want
to keep going without having this user
account working I need to figure out why
that's not working so now what I'm going
to do is since the half hour is up I'm
going to take just maybe a few more
minutes I'm going to check out the live
chat and see if I can answer any of your
questions somebody said now try logging
in I guess we could yeah I mean it
couldn't hurt let's go back over here
let's go to login still denied I'm like
I'm thinking I might have done something
really dumb like put in a space
somewhere and in either the the key file
or when I added the user and that's
what's messing me up because in terms of
the steps we took if you were following
along we hit all the steps the only
thing we skipped was actually creating
the key which we didn't need to do since
we already had one created so the only
other thing I could think of is it's
possible I accidentally copied the wrong
key I don't want to go through that
again uh that I don't think that would
be a good use of your time for watching
this to just watch me try to copy think
something again so I'll do that after
the video and for now let me try to
answer some of your questions
and also if anybody
shout it out where they're from well
read that out too so we have somebody
from the Philippines okay somebody asks
for a page that should set up a react
from scratch links in overall page
please yeah maybe I don't know if I set
everything up from scratch already in
the live stream it could be possible to
go back a few live streams and see that
as I said I think in the beginning I
really do want to do some very focused
short tutorials on each one of these
steps that I kind of do in my live
stream but we go through kind of quickly
so those are coming probably not until
sometime in June somebody recommended
Tyler McGinnis for his react courses so
that they're for beginners and they're
free that's cool if I get a chance I
might check that out too thank you for
the advice
oh yeah somebody said you created the
user but not put any key
I actually I put in the key but I put it
in on my other monitor but I'm I'm gonna
put it in again just to make sure I did
everything right night I put in the
right key after this video I may just
start completely from the beginning
someone said they're scared of using the
commands still stuck in the old-school
FTP once you get used to the commands
it's you get more comfortable with it
especially when you know I first set up
the server there's really nothing on it
if I completely mess the server up I
would just shut down the droplet and
start again and in fact if I can't
figure out what I did to mess up this
user account I probably will just shut
down the droplet and start again
hopefully I don't have to do that but
that's kind of the best time you know
play with some of these commands on a
fresh server or even on your local
machine if you can and and just get used
to them there
you know don't don't try them out for
the first time on a really important
live project but once you get used to
them they're nice and once again these
aren't off the top of my head I'm
following the instructions because I
don't trust my memory for this you know
for these type of things for the initial
setup
I won't I don't trust it to memory oh
cool somebody from Phoenix Arizona says
first time they get to watch the live
stream they've been watching the replays
so cool yeah maybe the different time
worked out better for some people
someone from Nepal is watching awesome
someone says it's the first time they're
watching a server setup well that's cool
I wish it would have went a little bit
better
does the SSH key generated on the local
machine work on the remote server what
yeah that's so basically the way it
works is you generate the key on your
local machine on your local machine then
get saved your private key and your
public key what
you want the the server to have is the
public key so then that public key gets
matched up with your private key
basically you never send your private
key anywhere that only stays on your
your local machine and then that's how
the keys are matched up so you can see
it's I mean it's a pretty secure setup
I'm someone would would basically have
to actually be on your machine to be
able to to get in you know through that
way okay somebody suggested using a
virtual machine to play around with even
if you break it you can reset it that is
great advice yeah and then you don't
even have to spend any money on a
droplet or anything virtual machine you
just set up for free
maybe said okay somebody mentioned I
can't see your terminal too well but
check that you copy the entire contents
of your public key so that's what I'm
kind of thinking that might be the
problem maybe I didn't get everything
copied maybe I was just trying to do it
too quickly didn't get it all copied now
that I think about that that's probably
the most likely solution all right
someone said I love the designing and
developing rather than setup yeah I said
it's something that you have to do if
you don't have anybody else working on
actually and somebody else set up the
other server that will host the
WordPress site so they set that up for
me which is awesome I just kind of
wanted to do this on camera instead of
have somebody else do it so that you
guys could see it in case you've never
seen it before and then we'll get back
to the designing and developing stuff
after we get this set up okay someone
suggested the Ubuntu forums topic
permission I'm public key err I'll check
that out I'm going to try to copy the
key over one more time if that doesn't
work I'm definitely going to check that
out on the forums someone says subscribe
to me so monstah miner MC says subscribe
to me that's not an endorsement I'm just
reading it out I don't really know what
their channel is is about I guess
minecraft no okay someone else we're not
done with with next and react are we no
we're definitely not done we've just
gotten to the point where I need to set
up the server where this will eventually
be housed when it's live I need to set
it up put something on there test it out
get the domain pointed at least a test
domain so because if we're going to
launch this next Thursday I like to have
all this set up well in advance in case
well something like this happens and I
mess it up so I don't want to put that
off until the last minute
somebody else said check the puppy file
contents that's I'm pretty sure that is
the problem someone's from Nepal someone
from India Argentina Holland Brazil
Poland Thailand another one from Brazil
all right I love it that you guys are
you know from all over the place from
Jersey in the United the United Kingdom
Channel Islands that's cool I'm in the
United States and when someone says
Jersey in the United States I thought
ways think of the state New Jersey and
forgetting that it's called New Jersey
because there was an original Jersey in
the UK Oh someone says the get up
student pack was denied oh man yeah
check how did I get it a Microsoft has
some sort of developer program that's
that's free I got a pretty good code
from that one so check that one out I
forget what it's called for sure but if
you type in something like Microsoft
developer program if you type that into
Google then I'm sure it'll come up
someone Rafael Bellini has put his email
in here in case anybody wants him for a
freelance job once again that's not an
endorsement I've never seen his work
before but he's put it on there someone
asks if there's any way I can practice
locally or free online yet locally I
mean you can practice some terminal
commands locally on your machine in
terms of server setup you you probably
will need to run a like a virtual server
if you install docker you can do some of
this in docker so you're probably you'll
need some tutorials to get used to
docker first but I would check that out
and then you know you can just do
whatever you want on the server if you
mess it up no big deal because it's just
a virtual server anyway so we have
someone from Saudi Arabia Belarus see
someone mentions VirtualBox to do the
virtual server so
you can do server virtual machine so
good all good suggestions someone says
it's my first time watching live in your
video channel awesome yeah maybe it's
not such a bad thing that I had to do
this at a different time of day and now
some you know different people get to
watch it live when maybe they couldn't
otherwise what if my hard drive dies I
lose my SSH keys why be able to log in
digitalocean does have a way to to log
in so I mean stai I wonder if I closed
my my screen with this version I think I
did now I have it here I'll show you
real quick um let me see I can't
remember where it is there is some
somewhere sorry guys I wanted to show
you but now that I look I can't remember
where it is I've never had to use it
there is somewhere on this admin panel
for digitalocean there is a spot where
you can reset the room pass okay you got
Brian Sizemore said Brian Sizemore is
the guy that set up my WordPress server
he's a colleague of mine here so he said
you can reset your root password in
digitalocean
and you can actually look use a terminal
right there in the browser from your
digitalocean
panel so you can still get in that way
this somebody asked that this will be
saved at the channel later it will about
five minutes after I stopped
broadcasting it should be saved as a
video so you can watch the whole thing
or pause or you know whatever you need
to if I went too fast
someone Cheezburger says Jesse we have
to cook so I'm not sure about that
actually I do really like to cook I post
pictures of my food on Instagram from
time to time so if you like to see
pictures of food you can check out my
Instagram but I don't think I'll be
doing any cooking shows any time soon so
we have somebody from New York City also
Brian sighs would recommend c9i oh so
it's cloud9 I I forgot about that yeah
that will give you like a cloud
development environment where there's a
server set up so you can test those
commands
well Windows Linux subsystem is easy to
set up all right so we have a lot of
great suggestions if you want to test
out your skills with the command-line in
a environment like a live server all
right and I bet to the end of the live
chat if you wanted to ask something you
didn't get a chance to or you just
didn't want to ask in front of everybody
you can either direct message me on
Twitter or if you don't care if
everybody sees your question just put it
in the comments below this video if you
want to see how we got to this point
check out my previous videos either on
free code camp or on my own channel
there's a link in the description I will
see you tomorrow at the same time again
today so 11:30 a.m. Eastern Time
thanks for watching have a great day